severodonezk activement bombardé par
moscou cette ville de l'est de l'ukraine
est l'un des nombreux fronts sur
lesquels russe et ukrainien se livre à
de violents combats depuis plusieurs
semaines la russie gagne du terrain
lentement mais sûrement
à ce jour environ 20% de notre
territoire est sous le contrôle des
occupants près de 125 mille kilomètres
carrés
c'est beaucoup plus que le territoire de
tous les pays du benelux près de 300
mille mètres carrés sont pollués de
mines d'obus qui n'ont pas encore
explosé
depuis la chute de marioupol le 21 mai
moscou contrôlent désormais tout un
corridor stratégique s'étendant de la
crimée à la frontière russe selon les
autorités ukrainiennes 12 millions
d'habitants ont quitté leurs foyers dont
plus de 5 millions ont fui vers
l'étranger
au début de leur invasion les russes
affirmé qu'il venait libérer le donbass
mais regardez ce qu'ils font ils
réduisent le donbass en ruines il
utilise toutes les armes à leur
disposition pour semer la terreur chez
les populations locales et pour détruire
les
séries selon l'otan la russie a mis en
place une guerre d'usure une stratégie
de rouleau compresseur qui semble porter
ses fruits pour inverser la tendance des
ukrainiens compte sur la livraison
d'armes américaines promise par joe
biden